I'm Roger Dannenberg and I'm an
associate research professor of computer
science music and art a laptop orchestra
is a collection of performers that play
laptop computers as instruments and this
is something that's become a fairly
common or popular form especially at
universities in and mainly in music
departments but often working with with
computer science departments so our
performance is going to combine multiple
laptop orchestras in fact we have seven
spanning from the west coast of the US
all the way to Huddersfield England and
these seven are going to be linked over
the internet connected by high quality
audio connections and also video
connections and they're also all running
software that's designed to allow me to
conduct what the players are playing as
far as we know we are by far the largest
organized performance of laptop
orchestras or any kind of network
musicians with with seven ensembles all
playing at once the course that these
students are in is called computer music
systems and information processing and
it's a class it's it's a computer
science class it's about how we
represent music especially about how we
build real-time interactive music
systems and so that includes a lot of
work on representing time and scheduling
and sort of mapping music concepts into
computer software and they have the
class has built all of this control
software it's a little bit frightening
to a to go on stage with with new
software that hasn't been thoroughly
tested but you know I think it's it's
part of the excitement and also it makes
it makes these projects really real for
students when the performance is
successful which I'm sure it will be
I'll be in a much better mood and I'm
sure that will have some effect on
grades